the whole world is overreacting
personally i don't think holding a
primary
that's unlawful yes there's been a
tightening
of freedom to express views
when china imposed a national security
law on hong kong last year it promised
that the principle of one country two
systems and the basic rights that it
enshrines would be upheld
but critics point to a rapid erosion of
freedom since
my guest this week is michael team
pro-beijing member of hong kong's
legislative council
and deputy in china's national people's
congress
he says the law needs clarification so
why does he still support it
[Music]
michael teen welcome to conflict zone
thank you hong kong has started off this
new year with mass arrest
53 pro-democracy politicians and
activists detained on the grounds of
subversion under the new national
security law
the move has been condemned by the
world's leading democracies rights
groups law associations as being nothing
more than a crackdown
is hong kong witnessing a dismantling of
its freedoms
and its opposition well i don't think so
first of all just like you and everybody
else in the world
we are busy fighting the pandemic
secondly the massive arrest that
happened
earlier this year is about a primary
being held last year involving
50 60 people who participated in the
primary
uh in preparation for last year's
electrical election
okay so so far the basis of that arrest
is that
the primary involves a lot of candidates
whose election platform
violated article 22
of the national security law which is
to paralyze the government to stop
everything from
functioning to basically oppose every
single funding and bill regardless
of its nature there comes electrical let
me ask you a little bit more about um
about about what has prompted these
arrests because actually this is
um what has shocked so many about these
latest arrests
um it has been the offense which has
been considered subversion
as you've articulated last summer um the
pro-democracy opposition they united to
decide
who might stand for elections they
essentially organized themselves um they
organized a primary
they were hoping to go for a majority in
the legislative council
they've been arrested here's how the
international community is reacting to
those arrests we have the incoming u.s
secretary of state saying the following
the arrests were an assault on those
bravely advocating for universal rights
we have the office of the un high
commissioner for human rights saying
these latest arrests indicate that as
had been feared the offense of
subversion under the national security
law is indeed being used to detain
individuals for exercising legitimate
rights
to participate in political and public
life so
in other words in a democracy this would
be seen
as standard politics but in hong kong it
gets you arrested
is that not disturbing to you
okay now are you ready to let me share
with you the background of this
now then you have to give me some time
the national security bill involves
article 20
which relates to secession in other
words going for
independence in that particular law
it's written very clearly that anybody
showing a motive
to do that will be deemed to have
violated the law
however with regard to article 22 of the
national security bill
which is not succession going for
independence from hong kong
but merely to topple the government
to paralyze the legislature to vote no
to everything
gaining control of legislature and all
that
there is an extra clause or condition to
that
which is that they have to do it through
unlawful means
now personally i don't think holding a
primary
is unlawful so therefore
if the primary invoice people whose
platform
are going for hong kong dependents yes
that would violate article 20 which
would mean
which would make the primary itself
uh dangerous the close to violating the
national security bill
however none of the candidates that
entered the primary
have hong kong independence as a
platform
however a lot of them have in their
platform
basic to come in and vote note to
everything and paralyze the government
however that has to be coupled with
unlawful means now the question that i
have been asking is is the primary
itself unlawful now i don't think so
right so therefore the police making the
arrest
therefore the police making arrests it's
only the first step
okay so in other words unlawful
practices
so in other words mr teen you're you're
you're calling for clarification
essentially um but you know i'd like to
look at some of the concerns
um that have been had and and for
example this is coming from the european
council
they have actually said these arrests
penalize political activity that should
be
entirely legitimate as as i've already
highlighted they say the national
security law
is being used
in hong kong you may have stifled
political pluralism in hong kong
the european parliament at this point is
calling on countries to consider
sanctions against targeted officials in
hong kong
the u.s has already imposed targeted
sanctions
as a result of these arrests it doesn't
get much more serious than that
and what you are calling for is just
clarification
okay now let me respond
they make all these arrests and
everybody is out on bail
secondly the government the secretary
for justice
have not even stopped prosecuting anyone
let alone that it may end up going to
the court
whether or not they'll be convicted or
acquitted
so this is simply the very first step
they are arrested on the basis of
suspicion
or violating article 22 of the national
security war
people get arrested and they're all
released on bail
on the base of suspicion of
violating the national security law now
let me ask you
every country in the world the most
democratic of the democracies
police arrest people now if they arrest
people and eventually
they're all off the hook and prosecution
don't move lean
don't move in then government lose face
or if the prosecutor comes in and they
lose all these cases in court
also the government would lose face this
is simply the very first step and the
whole world is now jumping on hong kong
saying well we don't have freedom we're
going
to credit this and that the world is
saying i have a job to explain to all of
you
cool down this slow first step
this is simply the first step they are
all released
on bear here's what human rights watch
has said what remains to be seen
what is important is that what specific
charge do they end up coming through
and do they go according to
everybody in the national security
law mr teen the world has been warning
that this is in fact the first step
toward repression
in fact there were warnings that this
would happen for example from human
rights watch who said that the hong kong
authorities with china's backing
are imposing mainland style repression
on a city long recognized for its
freedoms they say
hong kong's new security legislation is
nothing more than a road
map for repression don't these latest
arrests prove those warnings true
okay so if you want my honest opinion
the whole world is overreacting
and i'm supposed to be the most liberal
of the pro
beijing camp uh membership
the whole world is overreacting they
don't even know the details of these
arrests
or what it's all about
just like uh supporters of donald trump
in the u.s
but how about the hong kong government's
promise that this law would be used to
target only a minority of people mr tea
and i mean
carrie lam she she went on the airwaves
she actually spoke
before the united nations saying it
would only target an extremely small
minority of people who have breached the
law
while the life the property the basic
rights and freedoms of the overwhelming
majority of hong kong residents
will be protected that's a message that
you amplified that you echoed
for various uh journalistic publications
um tell me mr teen did you get it wrong
this doesn't seem like just a small
minority of people who have been
targeted
these are the leaders of the
pro-democracy movement the main figures
more than 50 people rounded up mass
arrests
why would you not believe kerry lam
because they've arrested only 50 people
and most likely a lot of them will never
be charged
the key is at the end who will be
charged
and on what basis don't we all have the
patience
to listen and see anymore
don't we are we all just getting super
hyped and super sensitive
these are people that join a primary
that's the only common factor among them
they are now looking into each of them
whether
in their the
journey towards uh participating in the
the primary whether they are violated
any section of the national security law
one of the key suspicion
is foreign government funding to fund
the primary
now if they can prove that then it's a
whole new different matter okay so you
say let the process
is targeted towards foreign government
funding
local opposition to right the national
uh government from hong kong you know
that so you say election process plan
debate with me about the merit of the
national security law now that's a
different issue
i don't think that's the purpose of
today's interview right
sentencing of pro-democracy activists
for example and politicians joshua
wong and agnes chao um and ivan lamb
back in december amnesty calls it a
warning shot for anyone who dares to
openly criticize the government that
they could be next
they say incitement which is what they
were
charged with and sentenced on refers to
the use of a megaphone
to shout slogans during a protest
is hong kong really afraid of people
with megaphones
is that what it's come to in any country
the likes of joshua law will be charged
with
treason he is actually going to
foreign government to ask them to
sanction
his own country you don't call that
i don't know what you call that that's
absolutely being uh
totally non-patriotic okay and it's
uh uh unthinkable
have you ever thought of that what if
american goes to china
and asked china to sanction the u.s
or a german legislator going to china
and asking china to sanction germany
because they are not happy
with what the german government is doing
how would you rate it let's just stay on
track here i mean that is not what what
he
uh was convicted of we have to say um
and also
in order to stay on track i'd also like
to ask you because the national security
law
is not the only action we know that was
recently handed down by beijing which
essentially
bypassed the hong kong legislature
in november four opposition members were
expelled from the legislature for
endangering national security
the chinese parliament it cleared the
way for the disqualification
with the passing of a resolution
allowing hong kong to expel legislators
deemed as a threat to security or not
holding allegiance to hong kong
was that a dark day for democracy in
hong kong
you said they expelled some legislators
no
the opposition quitted in their own
free will four were disqualified
because they were disqualified before
the last election
they no longer serve in the legislative
council mr team they no longer serve in
the legislative council
because they were kicked out they were
disqualified
there were four incumbent legislators
who entered the race and were
disqualified
from the race for this term so their
disqualification from entering the race
carries through to this
extended term this is a decision of the
national people congress the rest
of the opposition decide to
retire and resign all of their own free
will
i keep asking them to stay in because
actually i really
enjoy having them in the legislature
because they will provide a lot more
questions and answers
monitoring scrutiny government bills but
they decide to give up
and we will look at why they were
disqualified mr teen but you know
critics what they are pointing to here
and what is so concerning to so many is
the lack of due process
for these lawmakers the hong kong those
people
determined exclusively by the executive
by the chief executive carrie lam and
without affording them an opportunity to
be heard
violates the basic principles of
fairness and due process
inheritant in the rule of law again this
is coming from the hong kong
bar association so now anyone can be
dismissed simply at the whim
of the chief executive isn't that a
troubling sign for basic rights in hong
kong
where is the due process mr teen for the
four lawmakers
the four lawmakers that were
disqualified were disqualified
on the basis of their involvement with
foreign government but where is the due
process
can they appeal that decision they
cannot can they
of course they definitely can appeal
they don't know they can appeal that
decision
and they will go to the court yes
absolutely
we do have due process and if they lose
they can go to the appeal call
and if they lose they can go to the
court of final appeal
yes they haven't done that that's not
what
that's not what the hong kong bar
association says they said that legal
certainty has been greatly
impaired that it introduces an entirely
different way
to disqualify a legislator outside of
article 17
outside of article 79 and without
due process and i'd like to ask you in
that context
you disagree with the hong kong bar
association
they tend to generalize about everything
these four legislators that were
disqualified
definitely can and should appeal
and i think one or two of them will
probably win the appeal so
yes then let me ask you as a follow-up
how they should put
they should put the government to test
about this kind of disqualification
please understand i am not totally
behind
government the score finding these
people on all the grounds and specific
uh allegations that they make okay
because these people have not make a
defense
to the education made by the government
i am waiting to see them
put forth their defense challenging the
government
in the court and i think they are doing
that
and i don't know you know when that's
going to happen
i think we should all wait and see mr
teen another hong kong government may
not win all the time
mr teen another point that um you know
has concerned some is the language that
has been used by the chief executive in
in the wake of
uh the dismissal of these lawmakers she
said the following we need to have a
political body which is composed of
patriots she said she was excited that
bills will pass more efficiently
at the legislature in the future it
seems as if
there is no room for differing or
opposing views and voices
anymore in the legislative council how
does that serve the people of hong kong
ah that's a very good that's a very good
question
let me answer that objectively
if the chief executive basically want to
ram everything through let's go to save
time
i am the first to come out and
condemn her for making that statement
okay simply to make sure everything goes
through
minimize the questions okay and pass
billion dollar funding bill
within an hour or two all right
if you look at what's happening in the
legislative council for the last four
years
we're trying to elect a chairman of the
house committee
and that's been stopped for over nine
months
to a year and no bill can never go to
lexico
that's the other extreme of putting
everything to a stop
what i think kerry lam is saying is that
these people who run for office in
electrical
okay they can scrutinize the bill they
need to be
smart enough intelligent enough to come
up with questions
that make sense so filibustering
is an art you don't fill a buzzer by
repeating the same thing
for you know three months but mr t you
have
reason and you challenge government i
support that i've been doing that myself
sometimes government thing i ask too
many questions i'm okay i keep asking if
i don't repeat
the same questions 10 times 20 times
and that's what the opposition were
doing at one point
i think that's what carrie lane was
talking about
and there are concerns um as we have
mentioned um
that that there is an attempt now to
neutralize in fact
the opposition um in order to have
things run more smoothly for the
pro-beijing side
um for example the decision to postpone
elections by a year
um human rights watch has said the
following about that
they've said that in november 2019
pro-democracy candidates won local
elections overwhelmingly that
electoral showing seems to be why they
have alleged
carrie lamb's government has
disqualified pro-democracy candidates
for hong kong's legislative council
and in any event postponed those
elections for a year
they write what a better way to
neutralize the power of hong kong's
example
than by pretending that the city's
pro-democracy movement is the result of
nefarious foreign
influences was postponing the election
an attempt to neutralize the opposition
another great question
if covert 19
is not an act of god and there is
proof that there's a massive conspiracy
behind cover 19
that actually somebody somewhere
invented that
to mess up the whole world with the sole
purpose
of stalking stopping hong kong
legislative council election from going
on
then i would be very glad to hear the
evidence of that but mr team that is
and they point to nearby countries for
example singapore and south korea which
both recently held successful general
elections
without registering a spike in covid 19
cases
on the same side they look for example
at the disapproval ratings of carrie
lamb which most recently stood
at 72 and so now the elections
get postponed that doesn't look good
does it
first of all it's due to the pandemic
and then you said well many countries
have dependent yes
half of the world has the elections uh
held on a mail-in basis right
in hong kong we have a problem because a
lot of
our residents the voters live in samjhan
across the border and because of the
pandemic
we have quarantined uh issues and
basically the border was stopped so
a lot of these voters were deprived of
the right to vote
you mentioned in the beginning of our
conversation that you did not feel that
freedoms were under fire
due to the national security law but i'd
like to just point out another example
to you and this is when it comes to
freedom of speech and freedom of the
press
critics say there has been a swift
crackdown they point to the arresting
of a respected reporter who produced
reporting critical of the police
limiting of press cards forcing news
organizations to surrender materials
relating to pro-democracy candidates
arresting the head of the popular apple
daily jimmy lie
denying visas for no reasons to
reporters critical of beijing just a few
examples here
freedom of the press is it a casualty
of the national security law you
mentioned
about the arrest of mr jimmy eli mr
jimmy light has been behind a major
push okay to get foreign government
involved in funding opposition
activities in hong kong in my mind
mr jimmy light is not making positive
contribution
to one country to system all right
i don't want to be the judge but i don't
have any sympathy for him
if he's arrested you may think he is a
great
democracy fighter fighting for democracy
is one thing going to foreign government
to ask for sanctions to put pressure
on beijing all right to act differently
about
hong kong is something else they are
basically violating
the basic law uh the first article
which is hong kong is part of china and
it will never change
mr teen i'd like to ask you just briefly
before we go
claudia moe who is an opposition
lawmaker in hong kong
said that the aim of china's national
security legislation was to stun
hong kong into nothingness people will
be so petrified
so frightened so intimidated that they
wouldn't dare say anything or do
anything in opposition you have
articulated here that you are one of the
more liberal members of the pro-beijing
camp um you have sometimes
spoken out against the government do you
personally
have to watch what you say how worried
are you
let me be very honest with you i don't
want to be personal
about names okay so please spam me from
commenting about
my impression of joshua claudia law
or in fact joshua law or whatever
my honest opinion and feedback
is that yes there's been a tightening
of freedom to express views
particularly when it comes to hong kong
uh gaining some kind of a greater
control
over its own destiny all right about
a civic nomination that anybody can
nominate
to run for a chief executive and it goes
against the basic law so all i'm
saying is that if anybody comes up with
any kind of claim that goes against the
basic law
yes the freedom to express such views
is much less today than before because
of the national security bill
right we have to leave it there that i
agree michael team
thank you so much for joining us on
conflict zone
thank you
[Music]
you